so here at the Stampede what do you love
about about being here what do you love
about playing for this crap
well I rodeo for ten years through the
90s I was a team Oprah in the UST RC
circuit in the States this is one of the
greatest rodeos in the world yeah and
you know and this is home I got to make
a Western here with my father there was
the first time I saw the Stampede after
the terrible flood about eight years ago
and I saw the resilience of the people
here no one thought they were gonna be
able to pull off the Stampede this that
year it was actually a very emotional
kind of experience and so to be able to
come back here and play to this crowd
especially the kind of music that I play
kind of country rock it's an honor you
know as a Canadian kid you dream of
stuff like this yeah I think my first
dream was to be able to rodeo here but
playing here is gonna just suffice just
fine well if you were to jump in
tomorrow
mm-hmm what would your roping skills be
1 to 10 I could probably be around a
seven still I still play with a kid
wrote I wouldn't want to be healing I'd
be a header yeah yeah you know I heard
you saying that you were surprised that
your fans would be interested in your
music do you still feel that way now I
never said I was surprised I was
surprised how generous they were about
giving us the opportunity to play Frank
I'm very proud of the album's and I'm
proud of the music so I felt confident
that if people heard it that there would
be a percentage of them that would enjoy
it yeah but I was moved by the
generosity
of people coming out and and I think at
some point I was maybe a little cynical
and thought they were coming to see a
NASCAR race and wanted to see a crash
and our job was not to crash the car but
that wasn't true they wanted us to be
great
and they wanted us to do well and that
really moved me you know it's a very
different experience when you're making
a film or a television show there is no
direct contact with an audience yeah and
so this is a way for me to kind of have
a very personal experience with people
that have supported me for 30 years yeah
and it's been one of the most moving
experiences in my life it sounds like
it's an amazing thing to be able to get
to tour the country play for all these
people how long has the music been a
part of your life did you play a lot
growing up yes I mean my mother started
me on the violin when I was four yeah I
probably didn't enjoy it that much then
but I was I'm grateful for it now yeah
she got me a guitar when I was 10 and
that never left me and even when doing a
show like 24 a lot of these songs were
written during that period when they
were setting up shots or working out a
stunt sequence I just go in the trailer
and play and write some stuff down and
it's just kind of been the best friend
that's never left man is the inverse
true when you're on tour are you
thinking about the next role are you
thinking about what other acting gigs
you can do while you're on tour doing
music yeah I mean there's there's long
drives yeah
I love playing with a band that I play
with so we spend a lot of time together
but you know hopefully it's gonna be a
long life and there's other things that
I'll want to do but certainly about
three hours before show every ounce of
focus goes straight to that night and
and trying to put on the best show you
can yeah you know between your
successful acting career the music being
a rodeo champ it seems to me they just
go for things that you want well I'm the
luckiest guy I've ever met
you know I've been able to afford to do
things that I'm interested in yeah I was
very fortunate to have the opportunities
that I had early on as an actor I was in
a number of successful films and that
afforded me the opportunity to take time
off I had a farm in Montana that's how I
started to get into roping you know I
had a small label that was helping out
other bands in Los Angeles California
during the early 2000s that afforded me
the opportunity to meet with other
artists and start playing with them and
and learning how to write more
efficiently and so you know I've been
afforded the luxury of time the single
that we have out right now is called
something you love and it's really for
people who haven't been as fortunate as
I have and begging them to find some
time for themselves in their lives but
there isn't a moment that goes by in a
single day and every day that I don't
acknowledge how fortunate I've been
lucky lucky lucky is there such a thing
as downtime for you I have learned over
the years of downtime and I don't get
along very well and that I said I tend
to be happier when I'm involved in
something that I really enjoy there
isn't a single thing that I've done in
my life that really is a solitary sport
I'm not a tennis player don't you know I
play pool for fun yeah but even team
roping there's a team involved with a
band there's there's other people the
thing I've loved about working as an
actor is getting together with a group
of actors and a director and a
cinematographer and figuring out the
best way to tell that story
yeah so I get a lot of joy out of
spending time with those people but in
the process of trying to do something
creative yeah tell me about recklessly
me you've been just a title it's is a
relationship there well originally I
started writing about a horse
and that time between rodeo to rodeo in
that quiet drive to the next town and
then halfway through the song and I tell
this when we're doing the show kind of
it it's not really a joke halfway
through the song I couldn't remember if
I was writing about the horse or part of
my personality that I've had to try and
keep in check sometimes not very
successfully over the course of my life
and it's just it's an acknowledgement
and acceptance of Who I am
so the song really kind of wavers
between both things
um the gratitude that you feel for baby
Able's have lived a full life is amazing
you've also got a grandson right I have
two grandsons two daughters two
grandsons and two stepsons what are they
well your grandkids call you well their
dad is Scottish yeah and so and their
mom is his American and they get caught
in between a dialect when they're
starting so they call me grumpy yeah
instead of Grampy they call you grumpy
grumpy right and sometimes yes I am
grumpy no there's what's really funny is
the reason why we all laugh about that
is they don't quite understand what
grumpy is yes oh yeah well when they
started doing it now they've got it
sorted out they're older but that's not
yeah we used to laugh about it a lot how
much of your your film shows and your
music did they watch do they do they get
that thing with whatever say whatever's
age-appropriate yeah Hamish the oldest
grandson is playing guitar a lot now so
I've enjoyed playing with him and he's
he's moving at such a fast pace that I
know that that guitar will be with him
for the rest of his life so I'm happy
for him for that you know and for
Quintin was a little younger
whatever is age-appropriate the same has
come to you for advice
music advice or a career advice no just
you know if someone's got a little riff
you know what's a good core to to go
after this and
you know and but not direct advice so
there one of the things I was so
grateful about from my mother and father
when I started working as an actor
they let me find my way and I know that
that could not have been easy for them
because I've had to do it for my
daughter yeah but I was grateful for it
because it's the fastest way to learn
you know if you find your way to a
success than you learn that if you find
your way to a failure you learn from
that and so I was grateful for both of
my parents for letting me do that do you
ever feel anxious in between projects or
the idea that you're so looking forward
to do something new and something
different I am body anxiousness
you know whether it's doing that
championship season on Broadway the
215th performance was no easier than the
first yeah and the same with this will
you know we play 150 shows this year
easily the last ones no easier than the
first I work and feed off of that
nervous energy I hope that I figured out
over this many years to figure out how
to channel it and use it properly but
yeah it's just the way I'm built you
know yeah I'm a fan of designee a
survivor would you've been a huge hit
are we gonna see more if you could write
what Tom Kirkman is gonna do next
it was interesting with that character
is that no one argues with it and the
fact that he was a very stand-up morally
guided man at the beginning of the show
but when challenged with the presidency
of the United States the power and the
desire to maintain that will he falter
and that's the drama that's what's
interesting about that idea so he would
have to be continually challenged by
that in their moments
certainly in season 3 where he falters
and the question is can he regain it
and that's what I find dramatically
interesting about that character so as
long as he's being challenged with that
and it's also an interesting soundboard
for what's happening around the world
yeah politically there's been a
nationalist movement to the right in
countries if you would never have
expected it clearly something is
happening and so it's an interesting
show to present a kind of reflecting
board for what is in fact happening in
the world